I got birds don't mind the drones
they're a gift from an admirer of
Claire's gone forgetting up articles
comedian Tiffany Haddish is starring in
the new movie like a boss which open
your notes nationwide on Friday and it's
just one of three big films she'll be
appearing in in the months ahead
that's one mark of the incredible
success Haddish is now enjoying in the
entertainment world but some of her
latest projects are no act she's owning
who she is in her best-selling
autobiography the last black unicorn
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of Viacom CBS and in her new Netflix
special where a ceremonial coming-of-age
takes center stage
[Applause]
Tiffany Haddish has officially come out
do you know how difficult it is to be
black and Jewish in a hood count but I
couldn't read that good
Mitzvah celebrates her dad's roots
he was an Eritrean Jew from East Africa
and he came here to America met my mom
at a gas station in Booya on her 40th
birthday she went all out
hosting her very own bat mitzvah singing
the Torah alongside Billy Crystal I've
been learning Hebrew so I've been
learning my Torah portion never losing
that Haddish SAS you have no idea how
hard I missed a thing in a different
language first off you got to learn
language then you got a sink in the lake
and you got to be on key - yeah on key
she did it in front of comic pals Wanda
Sykes Kevin Nealon and Sarah Silverman
Silverman's sister even performed his
rabbi it's all just another day in the
life of a comedian on a tear so what's
the first thing you do when you go
onstage first thing I do when I go on
stage I go hi
whatever y'all how y'all doing how you
feeling I feel successful success
doesn't even begin to describe it
the last three years she's been on a
roll you're fired
from girls trip on the big screen making
me feel like I'm on an apprentice or
something you're pink champagne up to
the last og on cable you got some nerve
thinking you can crash my event how dare
you damn hello to you too you three
cannot do this and primetime Network TV
boy kids say the darndest thing but it
was her Emmy winning star turn on
Saturday Night Live now you big time you
balling out of control and I'm looking
at my bank account like uh-uh
the first featuring a black female comic
as guest host she says was the
industry's aha moment people think you
were an overnight success 19 in a 1999
and stand-up has been in the heart of
this comedian since her high school days
in South Central Los Angeles when a
counselor recommended her for summer
camp
at the Laugh Factory and they brought in
some pretty impressive community yes a
Richard Pryor Richard Pryor Richard
Pryor he says something to you
yes I'm never getting a sublet stage I'm
thinking about something give me he's
like stop stop what are you doing I'm
telling the joke he goes no you're not I
said what do you think I'm doing he said
you're getting on my goddamn nerves
that's what you doing he said look
people don't come to comedy shows to
hear about politics or religion or about
your life story they come to have fun so
when you're on stage you need to be
having fun and that is a philosophy that
I've tried to apply to everything that I
do in life I grew up in foster care
anybody else grew up in a system one of
her gifts has been making fun out of her
real life I'm the only special
foster care homelessness her father's
abandonment it's all detailed in her
memoir the last black unicorn did you
forgive oh yeah I have
after game I would want somebody to
forgive me I believe in treating
everyone the way I would want to be
treated right the golden rule and the
more I got to know them the more I got
to realize like maybe mentally
everything wasn't there maybe there's I
feel like there was a lot of fear
involved a lot of guilt involved things
that has nothing to do with me then
there are the things she hasn't talked
much about at all
yeah well I didn't talk about like being
raped by a police officer police cadet
okay I don't know how to make that funny
nothing there's nothing fun or funny
about that you know now I can't even
laugh at that man it's not there's
nothing funny about somebody stealing
something from you know that you'll
never get back it's not funny
and what do you do with that you just
use your son you just set that on the
shelf over there and then when it needs
to be addressed it's addressed and when
you need when it's time to share it work
I feel like maybe I had to have that
experience to help others heal or help
others speak their truth that's not
going to define my existence but she has
a laser-like focus defining her career
did you just say sheesh
don't be so judgmental which includes
her latest movie like a boss starring
alongside Rose Byrne and Selma Hayek
it's super fun it's about two best
friends who and roses playing my best
friend who has kind of like evolved into
one of my best friends even though we're
both from two different walks of life
like but we come together it's like
peanut butter and jelly we delicious how
much are you taking complete ownership
and control I'm trying to take a
complete ownership and control of my
entire destiny because at the end of the
day is my thoughts my vision my know-how
that's able to get things moving right
that's what I've learned like if if I
apply myself and believe in myself
enough I can set it up for a bunch of
people everybody
and she is ready for she is ready she
produces and writes all of her stand up
she wants more control in that arena as
far as movies are concerned and she is
just moving forward and ahead I mean she
has like five different projects going
on sometimes at the same time she sounds
like somebody I know
yeah you guys had a nice connect yeah we
did I really I really liked her yeah and
I love what she says people oh you're an
overnight success Oh who's this all of a
sudden I've been doing this since 1996
that's right
you